We often think of pin tucks as
horizontal lines across our knitting.
But we could do so much
more with this technique.
To review: pin tucks on the ribber
are formed with full needle rib.
All needles in work on both beds.
One of the beds is set to
slip for a few rows while the
other bed continues to knit.
The additional rows that are knit
will bubble up and form texture.
If we slip on the main bed and use punch
cards or electronic stitch patterns, we
can create lots of different textures.
In other words, we don't
have to slip an entire row.
Selectively slipping groups of needles
on the main bed while continuing
to knit the rows on the ribber,
we'll create texture like this.
Take a close look at this stitch pattern.
It's mostly black.
The white holes are needles
that will be slipping.
Remember, slip stitch means
the needle will not knit.
And the working yarn will
pass UNDER the needle.
When knitting on a single bed, this
forms floats across the purl side of the
fabric, and we often use the stranded
side as the public side of our knitting.
Because we're working full needle rib, the
ribber's stitches will cover the floats.
Texture will form when groups of needles
are slipped on the main bed and the
ribber continues to knit all  rows.
In this stitch pattern,
I slipped for four rows.
It created diagonal raised
areas of texture on the
ribber side of the knitting.
Looking closely, you can see
the distorted slip stitches on
the reverse side of the fabric.
This is the main bed side of the knitting.
Are you starting to
see some possibilities?
Here's a more complicated stitch pattern.
The needles were selected according
to the pattern and slipped.
As they were slipped,
the ribber needles continued to knit,
creating this interesting graphic texture.
Depending on your machine and
your yarn here are some tips.
It's recommended that you use the
fine knit bar on the main bed.
This raises the needles slightly
and can help with the knitting.
Play with the stitch
tensions between the beds.
If the main bed tension is too
loose, those strands can get sloppy
and catch on the sinker posts.
I had difficulty with this
yarn on my brother, 970.
Looking closely, there are sections
that are slipping 8 to 10 rows,
and I determined this was just too
many for my machine with this yarn.
In this example, the maximum
rows that are slipped are 4.
This
doesn't give as much texture,
but it knit a lot more cleanly.
When choosing or creating a pin
tuck pattern, please keep the
number of slipped rows in mind
for your machine and your yarn.